let's go
oh
come on Welcome back everyone this is my full
Shang Chi ending and post credit scene video
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs so we'll
break it all down help set up the future of
the marvel cinematic universe and the future of
avengers 5. if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos i'll be
doing full breakdown videos for the entire movie
this weekend too and a whole bunch of other bonus
videos careful for spoilers if you have not seen
the movie yet because we will be talking about
the ending everything that happened so at the
end of the movie when woo the mandarin finally
realizes that the voice that's been speaking to
him through the 10 rings this whole time isn't his
dead wife and shang chi michelle yeoh's character
the sister of shang chi's mother had been
telling him the truth about the soul eaters
and the extra-dimensional creature that they
call the dweller in darkness who is the real main
villain of the film the dweller in darkness is
actually one of the fear lords in marvel universe
they're the beings that prey on the fear of others
they're like cosmic beings that eat fear but in
the context of the movie they just say that it's
a creature from a different dimension that came
into the dimension of tao lao where her people
come from and started to consume all the souls of
their dimension before it would then come to the
main mcu dimension and eat everyone's souls there
more on that in a second but tao lao is confirmed
to be in a different dimension that's what happens
when they enter it through the waterfall they're
basically crossing through a dimensional portal
even though this isn't related to the iron
fist mythology it's a little bit like the idea
of kunlun in a different dimension the capital
cities of heaven the dimension that the dweller
in darkness comes from is called evereen he's also
one of the elder gods like cathone and schumacher
and in the comics like in the movie one of his
big tricks was telepathically manipulating people
the way he was manipulating wenwu during the movie
just speaking to him as the voice of his dead wife
trying to trick him and other people into helping
it escape so it had done this many times over the
centuries this many people had been come a voice
had been calling to them promising them lies
it's what lies behind the dragon scale gate
that was erected by the great protector the
people of the village in this dimension of tao
lao are living there to protect the rest of their
dimension as well as the main mcu dimension
from this threat of the dweller in darkness
and they've been doing it for about the past 4
000 years the reason why he looks a little more
like cthulhu in the comics like he has the squid
head with tentacles is because jerry conway in
the comics created him to be marvel's version
of cthulhu obviously they went with a slightly
different direction for the character in the
movie after wenwu sacrifices himself to save
shang chi from the dweller darkness he passes
the ten rings to him then gets his soul sucked
out so he's permadead r.i.p mandarin and so
was their mother if that wasn't clear all the
stuff about her soul being trapped behind the
gate was a lie told by the dweller in darkness
shang chi uses the ten rings to destroy the
dweller in darkness using a legit finishing move
like he goes full dragon ball and big dragon ball
easter egg katy calls it a kamehameha during the
movie if you're not a big dragon ball fan or not
big anime fan the kamehameha was like the first
big type of energy power up attack depicted
on that franchise and it was kind of like
the precursor to the super saiyan power-ups and
dragon ball z later maybe they'll make more goku
references to him about when he learns to harness
the full power of the great protector dragon more
in future sequels and if it wasn't clear the
reason why his energy is yellow like that instead
of blue like his father's because his energy is
the same color as the energy his mother gave off
when she was using the ten rings at the beginning
of the movie when they were explaining wenwoo the
mandarin's backstory she said that her power
was a gift from the great protector dragon and
i think it works the same way that peter quill's
celestial powers work when he was in proximity to
ego the living planet he could form things around
himself he could give off celestial energy attacks
but when he's not near ego he seems more like
a normal person they never fully explain this
during the shang chi movie i think they'll get
into it more in the sequels but my theory is
right now that they're able to draw on the power
of the great protector dragon because it's like a
demigod from their dimension like another type of
celestial being the same way the ego living planet
was a celestial inside the mcu and these people
in the tao lao village are its descendants many
hundreds of thousands of years removed the way
they narrate the backstory of the fight between
the dweller and darkness and the great protector
dragon just makes it sound like it's a celestial
being from their dimension in Shang Chi's mother
when he's a young boy tells him you have the heart
of the great protector dragon i think that's both
a metaphor and i think she meant it literally
like he literally has some of the same dna as
the great protector dragon the way that peter
quill has celestial dna in him and that's why
she is able to wield its energy like that and
this also gets into the origin of the ten rings
and how they actually work inside the mcu more on
that in a second too when we get to the mid-credit
scene with wong hulk and captain marvel because
that's basically all about the power of the ten
rings they seemingly kill the dweller in darkness
even though in the comics it was created from the
manifestation of people's fears and you can't kill
fear but in the mcu i think they just wanted
to be an extra dimensional being like dormammu
and if doctor strange got a significant power up
the way he did during what if episode four like if
he went full evil doctor strange he could become
powerful enough to kill dormammu so you can kill
beings that are that powerful you just need more
power yourself they don't completely explain what
happens to trevor at the end of the movie but i
believe they just let him go back to the main mcu
dimension on earth and go free when shang chi katy
and his sister went back to san francisco although
his sister goes back to his father's compound but
then getting to the mid-credits scene he and katy
are having dinner with their same friends from the
beginning of the movie who were giving them a hard
time about not living up to their potential and
they're telling their story about the adventure of
the movie without missing any beats like literally
telling them everything that happened without
lying about it giving away all the spoilers
because remember this world knows about aliens
thanos the infinity gauntlet even at the beginning
of the movie the same friend was the one that
referenced the snap we're living in a world where
half of us could just die at any time so you have
to remember that in the mcu now ground level
just normal people aliens thanos the infinity
gauntlet that's all common knowledge so it's not
weird to have conversations like that anymore
but their friends still don't believe their story
about going to a different dimension in tao lao
until wong shows up opening a portal into the
middle of the restaurant and starts yelling for
shang chi and tells him to bring the ten rings and
for both of them to come for an avengers meeting
inside the sanctum wong steals one of their drinks
on the way out real quick just downing it in a
single gulp wong does like to have his fun as we
see later after the mid-credit scene taking a trip
to the hotel california but if it wasn't clear the
room where this meeting is happening with all the
books is the library at the sanctum which is why
i say this scene is happening before the events
of the spider-man no way home trailer because
there's no giant snow drifts all over the place
wong is holding an advanced zoom call meeting
with the hulk who's completely changed back
into banner from professor hulk his right arm
is still in the sling so it's still all gimpy
permanently damaged it seems but aside from the
infinity gauntlet damaged arm he seems pretty
normal and healthy otherwise captain marvel has
her same costume from avengers end game but she's
grown her hair out long again since the events
of endgame so a little bit of time has gone by
they're using the same type of technology
that they use during avengers end game for
the conference call because captain marvel is
still in the cree scroll part of the universe
wong says the reason why he called this avengers
meeting is because when shang chi used the ten
rings to kamehameha the dweller in darkness wong
says that everyone in kamar taj he dr strange all
the sorcerers in the main mcu dimension felt
it and when he says they felt it he means they
sensed it like since some incredible cosmic
power was being used like sensing when thanos
the hulk or iron man were using the infinity
gauntlet wong says that there are no records of
the 10 rings in any of the sanctum's codex they
keep records of all magical artifacts and items
in their universe so that confirms that the ten
rings came from another dimension and bringing
it back around to the weishang she and his
mother were able to use their dragon energy
great protector energy to wield the ten rings in
a more powerful way than when wu did i think the
movie pretty clearly implied and michelle yeo's
character implied that the ten rings came from her
people's home dimension of tao lao even though she
doesn't clearly explain that to shang shi like he
asked her point blank what do the ten rings have
to do with any of this but then she launches into
that big exposition dump explaining the history
of her people from that other dimension of tao
lao but during that speech she never mentions
the 10 rings again she just talks about the war
between them in the dweller and darkness and how
the great protector dragon showed up to help them
at the beginning of the movie it's actually shang
chi's mother who's narrating the story of the ten
rings for him she talks about the legend of the
ten ring xiangxi there are many things that you
need to learn about the ten rings but some of that
will come later during that she says the legend
of how the mandarin found the ten rings changes
over time some people say that he found them in a
crater some say that he found them in a cave those
are just references to the original iron man comic
book version of the mandarin and how he found the
ten rings inside the valley of the sleeping dragon
in the comics the rings themselves were actually
just devices to power the mcluhan spaceship which
it crashed and that's how the rings wound up on
planet earth in the mcu they're doing something
different with the rings i'll talk about that more
in future videos where i think they're going to
take the sequels because i think they're doing
some of the mcluhan stuff from the comics but
just changing it a lot saying that it's all coming
from this different dimension but then using the
avengers technology to study the rings the hulk
says that they're basically older than anything
that wong and doctor strange's books have records
of michelle yo's character did say that her people
came to the village about 4 000 years ago and it
seems like they live natural lifespans but are
genuinely humanoid with some dna from the great
protector celestial being perhaps then they pull
a big zoom in enhance on the 10 rings themselves
and find out at the atomic level they started
emitting this signal when shang chi used them
to kill the dweller in darkness but they have no
idea who the beacon is broadcasting to only that
someone super ancient and powerful from the comics
listening for that beacon someone who would have
been old enough to have created the rings which
are bare minimum eternals level old and they're
about seven thousand years old i know a lot of
people after the movie were trying to connect this
scene to the eternals characters but i think it's
actually setting up something different in the
future for avengers 5 because chongqi's yellow
energy is a different color entirely than the
eternal celestial energy and the eternals are from
the main mcu dimension the ten rings the great
protector dragon chongqi's energy are all from a
different dimension of tao lao so the big cosmic
being that the beacon is contacting is probably
from the dimension that his mother's people are
from also because captain marvel is here for all
this i think it's a sly wink and a sinister
twist on the space pager avengers infinity
war post credit scene where nick fury activates
the souped-up space pager to contact her across
the galaxy like the 10 rings are a cosmic energy
level power up space pager broadcasting across
dimensions to someone super powerful and they'll
pay that off more during the shang chi sequel and
theoretically it'll also be a plot point setting
up avengers 5 because the way wong was hyping
it up he made it sound like the avengers would be
dealing with whoever shows up to answer that page
my early theory is that it would have to be
somebody as big as galactus the way they're
hyping this up is a huge avengers level threat
and i don't think this has anything to do with
the kang multiverse war i think this is
completely separate the whole thing with a
dweller in darkness was sucking people's souls out
galactus literally sucks the life out of planets
so they could just be trying to set that up slowly
in the future of the mcu you guys can let me know
in the comments though who do you think that
beacon inside the 10 rings is broadcasting to
like what is the celestial being or the cosmic
being that's listening for that but then captain
marvel logs off the call they have a joke about
her phone number hulk says she does this all the
time and i don't have her number that's just a
joke about captain marvel never being around to
help earth out they actually will cover that as a
big plot point during captain marvel 2 the marvels
the fact that she's super powerful but she's never
around to help on earth and everyone being super
pissed about it they teased that a little bit on
Wandavision with monica rambeau's character but
then wang says their lives Shang Chi and katy's
lives are about to change in a big way gives them
a welcome to the team speech which is the movie's
way of saying welcome to the avengers then they
bring back that karaoke joke from the beginning
of the movie like we're super tired we have this
big life ahead of us doing avengers stuff so we
should be responsible and get to bed early or
and then they go back to karaoke with wong singing
hotel california which was the song the katy sang
when they were in high school to just confuse the
bully that was getting ready to fight shang shi
it's just a joke about his friendship with katy
but who knew wong liked to have so much fun
now it makes a little more sense why he
was having that fight with the abomination
why he seemed so friendly with emil blonsky
like he calls him by name during the movie
i will do a separate video about the abomination
and what was going on with him during the movie
because they teased something really big going
on with him but they never completely explain it
and he just kind of goes away in the middle of the
film i do think it has something to do with what's
going on with vala's character putting together
the thunderbolts the dark avengers style team
but val herself does not appear anywhere in the
film then in the post-credits scene his sister
zealing is back at their father's compound
and takes over the ten rings organization
and changes things physically and metaphorically
so that now they have women assassins as well
those were not black widows those were just
regular ten rings soldiers warriors assassins
she kind of upgrades her former fighting
competition organization using the 10 rings
like she even has her little fight promoter there
from earlier in the film there's all this graffiti
decorating her father's compound just like
the graffiti around her fighting ring in macau
she's also changed the flag in the symbol
of the 10 rings giving it more red coloring
she says they have a lot of work to do and then
the tag at the end reads the 10 rings will return
using her new version the 10 rings logo obviously
they will be back for shang chi too in the sequel
but i think the whole point of the tag here
reading 10 rings will return means that we'll
see them in another movie sooner than that and
because of all the shady stuff that sharon carter
is doing as the power broker now in marvel face 4
and val is doing on the dl separately i think that
we might see the 10 rings come back during captain
america 4. like a lot of people mistook macau the
location of her fighting ring for madrapore
so it seems like she is a character already
fits in with a lot of what's going on with the
falcon and winter soldier power broker stuff but
post all your theories about that in the comments
below when is the next place that we'll see these
version of the 10 ring show up in a movie i'll do
my full easter eggs breakdown video for the entire
movie next and talk more about what's going on
with these people from another dimension and tao
lao the ten rings themselves the other huge cosmic
questions that they didn't answer during the movie
if you do have any questions about the
movie that you want me to include in
that just write them below in the comments
everyone click here for my full spider-man
no way home trailer video and click here for
my full what if episode 4 evil doctor strange
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!